turning now to uvalde texas we are
learning dramatic new details from a mom
who ran inside the school as the
shooting unfolded to get her children
out she was among the parents who were
held back by police while their children
were trapped inside rob elementary
school lilia luciano spoke exclusively
with the mother lilia we've seen these
headlines from this story and it's just
the more you hear the worse it gets good
morning to you
that's right good morning gail we spoke
with angeli gomez she's she had two of
her sons who had graduations that
morning she came to rob elementary she's
a farm worker she was telling me that
she was embarrassed to take photos with
them because her clothes were dusty but
her kids convinced her and she's glad
she did that because those could have
been the last photo she took with them
her children are safe but after that
happened she went back to work and while
she was at work within 10 minutes her
mom called her frantically saying there
was a shooter so like many parents she
got in her car and drove like a hundred
miles an hour to get to the school
here's what she told us
right away as i parked
us marshall started coming toward my car
saying that i wasn't allowed to be
parked there and he said well we're
going to have to arrest you because
you're being very uncooperative i said
well you're going to have to arrest me
because i'm going in there and i'm
telling you right now i don't see none
of y'all in there y'all are standing
with snipers and y'all are far away i'm
if y'all don't go in there i'm going in
there he
immediately put me in cuffs she says
after uvaldi police officers told
marshals to uncuff gomez she ran towards
the school as soon as they uncut me i
jumped that first gate fence and once i
jumped it i went to my son's class
and i knocked on the door and i remember
the teacher saying
i'm like hey they're already they're
already boats cutting the fence to get
me she's like you think we have time to
get out he said you'll have time i'm
going to run for my other son once she
was assured her son was ok gomez ran to
get her other child encountering more
officers who tried to stop her so i
start yelling and i'm being a
cooperative and i'm like well y'all
aren't doing what are y'all doing
y'all need to be in here give me your
best somebody give me a bed some
something i started paying attention to
how far the shots were being so that i
knew the shooter was all the way still
by my first son's class so when i went
to my set my second son's door the
teacher didn't want to open the door for
me so that's when they started um
escorting me out and as
i see that they're opening my son's door
i go run for my son and i get him with
both of her kids out safe gomez still
can't shake the thought of those who
didn't make it while you were inside the
school did you see officers there inside
an officer inside the school when i ran
class there was not one officer and you
were hearing gun shots so you knew you
could hear that it was an active shot it
was still active the gunshots were still
active they were not in there there was
no one in there if anything when i
pulled up my car was closer to the
school than that then where the snipers
and everybody that was laying on the
ground were when you heard that it took
law enforcement 75 minutes before they
went in and stopped the shooter what was
your thinking having been inside the
school yourself
i don't know i was just thinking that
they could have saved many more lives
they could have gone into that classroom
and
maybe
two or three would have been gone but
they could have saved a whole
a home or the whole class they could
have done something gone through the
windows sniped them through the window i
mean
something but nothing was being done if
anything they were being more aggressive
on us parents that were willing to go in
there and like i told one of the
officers i don't need you to protect me
get away from me i don't need your
protection if anything i need you to go
in there with me to go protect my kids
and if anything they were being more
aggressive on us they're more pertain on
keeping us back then getting into that
school
many parents have expressed that same
frustration that they weren't being let
in of course law enforcement couldn't
let all the parents in for everyone's
safety and so they could focus on
evacuating the children now in terms of
where she was it sounds like she was at
a different area for from where those 19
officers were we know from law
enforcement that there were officers
that were right outside of where the
shooting was happening and najelli said
she was with an ear shot in terms of the
weight now law enforcement has admitted
gail that this was a big and costly
mistake
yeah oh that's one way to put it my
heart's racing lily listening to mrs
gomez number one
that's one of the most articulate most
graphic descriptions from somebody who
was there who
really was telling us in real time what
was happening i'm so glad she's all
right and that she got her children and
she's raised a lot of disturbing
questions a lot of people watching that
day nodding along
the whole time i was riveting your
points
go ahead lilia she knows many parents
who lost their kids she works with one
of those parents who lost their kids so
she feels lucky for her children but
she's struggling
yeah i can i can see that too i feel
that lilia thank you yeah i i don't i
don't know the procedures for law
enforcement so it's hard for me to speak
on why they did or did not do something
yeah um but like you said her account
very articulate very graphic very heroic
yes there is nothing like a mother who
wants to save her child and what she'll
do to go through that she was not
exaggerating not at all she was just
telling us what happened to her that day
running through a school with gunshots
going on yeah fearlessly without a vest
saying i am going to save my child's
life and she did she did and she did
both of them